Und es ist Samstag und ich bin wieder am Start.
Ja, das Podcast-UFO ist, hey, richtig lit. Richtig lit. Auch mal was für unsere Gen-Z-Millennial-Gangs. Das war Gen-Z, weiß ich doch jetzt nicht. Alle sind willkommen. Alle sind willkommen, das Portal ist geöffnet, alle sind willkommen, alle können reinkommen und sich hinsetzen. Und es gibt ja ein gewisser Weltschmerz, der auch generationenübergreifend ist. Stefan. Natürlich, aber um auf einen anderen Punkt einzugehen, mir sind die Intros jetzt zu kurz. Auf, nein, auf, hör auf, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, natürlich. Aber um auf einen anderen Punkt einzugehen, mir sind die Intros jetzt zu kurz. Oh nein, hör auf, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, hör auf, das kannst du nicht sagen. Da war noch so viel Potenzial! Das kannst du nicht sagen. Nee, das kannst du nicht sagen. Wirklich, ich schneide die Stutztier runter wie ein Bonsai-Baum und jetzt kannst du nicht kommen, Wildwuchs Stefan. Leute, wir müssen nicht unter dem Florentin-Regime hier leben und leiden.
Nein, wir können entscheiden, was wir wollen.
I can't do this on my own.
Stopp!
Aus!
Raus hier!
Bum bum bum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum dum Stopp! Stopp! Los geht's!
Aber das ist so, wir hatten damals zum Beispiel dieses tolle Intro, die Stationen geben go.
Ja, von Sebastian. Das war so lang!
Ja, wenn die richtig gut sind, können sie auch lang sein, aber...
Was ist das denn für eine Regel?
Tobi! Vielen Dank an Tobi für dieses fantastische Intro, du hast uns ein bisschen reingeholt. Es ist Samstag, ihr seid gut gelaunt, die Sonne brennt und glüht euch auf die Glatze runter und ihr freut euch. Auf die Sonne, boah, es gibt diese gruseligen Bilder. Ich habe ja die Sonne, ich unterstelle es ja die Sonne immer. Ja, das ist mir schon oft aufgefallen. Und dann gibt es diese gruseligen Bilder von Lkw-Fahrern, die oft links dann so super sonnengegerbte, ledrige Feuerhaut haben, Lava-Haut und rechts jungenhafte, schöne Gesichter. Grossartig. Nein, nicht grossartig. Bei denen ist es andersrum. Bei denen ist es genau andersrum. Und die japanischen,
die sollten sich auch nochmal zusammentun.
Eigentlich sollte man als Lkw-Fahrer die Hälfte seiner
Karriere in Deutschland fahren und die andere
in Japan. Das finde ich gut. Linke Seite, rechte
Seite. Dann sind beide kaputt.
Dann sind beide kaputt.
Aber beide auch jugendlich frisch, also dann beide ausgeglichen.
Symmetrie.
Ja, okay, gut, jetzt kannst du wieder sagen,
willst du beide Seiten angedotzt oder willst du eine noch gleich. Aber das, glaube ich, das kann jeder sich selber entscheiden. Da gibt es ja wirklich keine. Aber tatsächlich, die Sonne ist ein kräftiges Kerlchen, glaube ich, kann man wirklich mal sagen. Muskelmann. Du kannst ja wirklich innerhalb kürzer Zeit dir alles kaputt machen, Körper kaputt, Augen kaputt, Wonne-Protz, ein richtiger Wonne-Brocken. Die Sonne ist ein Wonne-Proppen. Glaube ich astronomisch sogar tatsächlich, gesichert diese Aussage, ist ein heisser Wonne-Proppen, kann man mal sagen. Pass ein bisschen auf, mir ist aufgefallen, die ist heisser als man denkt. Ey, Lupen sind so krass, da gibt es so manchmal so YouTube-Kanäle, die einfach so eine riesige... Anderes Thema jetzt. Nee, die eine riesige... Nein, es geht schon darum, dass Sonnenlicht durch die Lupe scheint. Ich sage nicht einfach, ich liebe Lupen, meine Dinge, die nah am Fernsehen sind, nah, boah, Lupen. Nee, es geht schon darum, dass wenn du eine Lupe in die Sonne hältst, dass du ein ...
Wie jemand, der kein Smalltalk kann und plötzlich ganz andere Sachen ausserdem nicht sagt, mitten im Gespräch. Meine lieblingsste Figur bei Game of Thrones ist Tyrion Lannister. Hä, Moment, Luisa hat uns gerade gesagt, dass sie keine Gefühle mehr hat mit Marco, aber trotzdem schwanger ist. wobei die White Walker ja auch, könnten die überhaupt bis in die Wüste vordringen. Hey, darum geht es jetzt gerade nicht. Darum geht es jetzt gerade nicht. Wir hören uns kurz der Luisa zu, weil sie hat keine Gefühle mehr für Marco und ist schwanger. Ja, ich habe keine Gefühle mehr für Marco, bin aber von Marco schwanger. Ich weiss nicht, ob es zusammenhängt. Ob ich Marco so als Sexhengst sehe, aber nicht als Vater. Ist mir aufgefallen, dass wenn man in kleine Löffel reinguckt von und die sind konkaden, dann sieht man sie auf dem Kopf. Das ist lustig, weil wenn man sie umdreht, dann ist man richtig rum. Man sagt ja immer, Karpfen haben kein Gedächtnis. Stimmt nicht. Habe ich letztens gelernt und die können sich bis zu drei Zahlen merken. Na jetzt überlege ich abzutreiben. Auf jeden Fall Lupen, du kannst ja eine Menge machen, ne? Also das ist wirklich ein fucking Todesstrahl, den du mit, du kannst wirklich einfach Steine zerstören. Der Typ hat eine fucking Lupe gebaut, mit der du einfach die Sonnenlicht auf den Stein fokussierst und der Stein sagt so, wow, ich bin raus, ich geb auf, ich geb auf, ich bin raus und der Stein, pff, nee, es gibt Steine, so, die sind krass, und es ist einfach nur die Sonne, das ist fokussiert, so ein Laser, es ist so krass, es ist einfach ein fucking Sonnenlaser, wenn wir das einfach nur auf interplanetarer Ebene nutzen könnten als Waffe, wir könnten den Mond ein für allemal loswerden. Florentin, der Mond ist nicht unser Feind. Doch, der Mond, der nimmt uns das Wasser weg. Wohin? Der zieht uns das Wasser aus der Niere raus. Wohin denn? Weg ins Albe! Der macht gar nichts! Gezeiten, der haut das Wasser raus. Mit jeder Flut verlieren wir 100 Hektoliter Wasser in die Atmosphäre, saugt er die raus. Florian, es gibt keine Beweise dafür. Der saugt das Wasser raus. Das ist eine Intervention, okay? Du bist, also wir sind alle froh, bestimmt nicht falsch, dass du kein Flat-Earth-Hummer bist, okay? Das tut mir leid. Und ich weiss doch, wir waren super happy, dass du uns dann gesagt hast, wir sind es nicht mehr und du hast ja eingelesen und so. Und wir dachten, jetzt ist alles gut. Aber dann kam es mit dieser, der Mond klaut uns das Wasser Idee um die Ecke. Es gibt keine Anzeichen, es gibt wissenschaftlich keine Anzeichen dafür. Du nimmst mal einen Topf voller Wasser und wir stellen den mal raus. Alles klar. Und dann schauen wir mal, was passiert. Ja, aber das ist nicht der Mond. Naja, das ist nicht der Mond, das sagt sich leicht von der indoktrinierten Schlafschafseite. Natürlich, jede Nacht zieht der Mond ein kleines bisschen runter. Aber warum der Mond? Die Wassersteuer. Warum kann das nicht ein Hund sein, der daraus trinkt? Oder ein Hund? Ja, oder Kondensation oder so. Das kann ja einfach weg sein, das muss ja nicht der Mond. Warum ist der Mond der einzige Verdächtige?
Du meinst, die Hunde nehmen uns das Wasser weg, oder was?
Nee, jetzt will ich dich nicht auf eine andere Verschwörungstheorie bringen.
Fucking Köter!
Hör auf, lass die leg die Waffe nieder, dann nieder.
Leg deine Harbune nieder.
Aber ganz kurz, hast du mal auf den Mond geschaut?
Stundenlang.
Das Arschloch.
Ich hab gewettert. Ich hab wirklich stundenlang gewettert. Wenn er sich mal zeigt, feiger Arschloch, ist er die meiste Zeit abgehauen. Wo ist er denn? Und das grosse Auge des Mondes, aber wenn du drauf guckst, siehst du da Wasser? Siehst du da Wasser? Manchmal sehe ich Glimm und Glitzer. Nee, eben nicht. Sag einfach die Wahrheit, sie ist kein Wasser. Ja, das Wasser ist, nee. Wo ist das Wasser? Das ist nämlich das Ding, der saugt das Wasser raus aus der Erde. Wie soll das aufgehen? Und bei der Schwerkraft, der saugt die raus. Gezeiten, okay? So, und dann zieht er das raus und dann ist er aber schon weg, wenn das Wasser in die Richtung kommt. Und dann ist das Wasser weg. Wo ist das Wasser? Es fliegt in die Unendlichkeit. Der Mond ist knochentrocken. Du verstehst mich einfach nicht. Ich glaube, du willst mich nicht verstehen. Hör auf die Fakten. Der Mond ist schon so lange da. Der hätte uns das Wasser schon klauen können. Der ist schon länger da, als du lebst. Wir hätten jetzt die einmalige Chance, den Mond zu zerstören, und ihr seht es nicht. Und ihr werdet euch wirklich in zwei, drei Jährchen, in mickrigen Jährchen, werdet euch umdrehen und ihr werdet euch so ärgern. Ihr werdet euch so ärgern, dass wir diese historische Möglichkeit nicht genutzt haben, um einfach mal den Mond loswerden zu können.
Ich mag den Mond.
Weg mit dem, so.
Was hat er dir je gegeben?
Wundervolle Vollmondnächte, in denen ich nicht schlafen konnte, okay, aber...
Mondwasser, gut. Es gibt abgefülltes Mondwasser, das im Mondschein abgezapft wurde. Moment, Moment, Moment, ach so weisst du, ja, okay. Tatsächlich. Wolvik. Ist Wolvik Mondwasser? Ich glaube, die nehmen das auch mit so. Uns ist scheissegal, wenn wir das abzapfen, aber dann halt Mondwasser, warum nicht? Mond. Mondwasser. Mond. Le Monde. Le Le monde, ja, die Hand. Ne, ne, le monde gibt uns viel. Le monde, die Erde, monde. Ist das nicht das Rennen? Naja, komm. Le monde, der Mann. Ich habe schon wieder alles vergessen. Hast du aufgehört zu lernen, französisch zu lernen? Aufgehört zu, ich habe angefangen, wieder zurückzulernen. Ich habe wieder, ich haue die Kisten gerade raus, ich misste aus, es ist alles gerade raus und es bringt nichts. Also ich versuche schon noch so aufrechtzuhalten. Ich habe da ja während meiner französischen Lernzeit so ein paar französische Influencer kennengelernt. Influencisse? Influencisse? Böse! Und hab den natürlich, folgt den immer noch und kriegt deren Videos natürlich immer noch in die Timeline gespült.
Ja.
Und dann schaue ich da immer noch rein und verstehe kein Wort und das ist wie ein alter Kumpel aus der Schulzeit, die nun mal gut kannte, der jetzt einfach nur noch in Begriffen redet, die du nicht verstehst. Es ist traurig, melancholisch, französisch. So muss es sein. So gehört es dir das. So mag ich das. Aber du, ich habe ja auch mal Sprachen gelernt mit einer App und dann steigst du auf, Level zwei, Gamification, alles cool, macht Spaß. Ah, Level drei, ich glaube, ich bin bald Muttersprachler. Crazy, wie gut ich bin. Nein, ich bin nur gut in diesen speziellen Level-Mechaniken. Und dann kommt Level vier und man denkt, ah, jetzt bin ich gleich fertig, also jetzt kann ich gleich Abhandlungen schreiben in der Sprache. Und dann guckt man mal bei Leuten, die das schon jahrelang jeden Tag machen und deren App, gleiche App, sieht ganz anders aus. Und die schreiben Sätze und die schreiben und schreiben und das ist so krass. Und dann hören sie in Hörbeispiele und haben so Game Mechanics, die ich noch nie erahnte habe. Die haben den Paladin mit dem Zweihandschwert. Das ist so krass. Da guckt man mal auf ein anderes Duolingo-Level und man merkt, ich bin doch nirgends. Naja, du merkst, ich hab die Kindervariante? Ich hab die Kleinkindvariante da? Das ist so krass. Was soll das denn? Das ist so krass. Rächerlich. Von daher, ich glaube, es liegt einfach an einem selber, weil man ist dusselig und lernt nicht zu Ende. Wir haben Post bekommen. Und zwar, du wirst dichn wir haben gerade eine community aktion am laufen kann vielleicht einmal kurz einleiten wenn ihr das podcast ufo gehört habt während ihr geblitzt wurdet dann geben wir euch geld dafür wir geben euch nämlich was dazu oder zahlen sogar eure ganze in die mit der sitz geben wir euch nämlich geld zu eurer blitzerrechnung, zu eurem Knöllchen dazu. Genau, in unserer aktuellen Aktionen, Podcast mit Verantwortung. Stimmt das? Ja, stimmt völlig. Ja, stimmt hundertprozentig. Sehr gut, sehr gut, Stefan. Nicht schlecht, du entwickelst dich weiter. Deine Sprachkenntnisse sinken, aber deine Podcastverantwortung als Co-Moderator steigt. Und zwar, ihr erinnert euch wahrscheinlich an Michael. Michael hat uns seine dramatische Geschichte geschildert, er wurde leider geblitzt, weil er auf der Autobahn... Erzähl doch nochmal, das ist eine spannende Geschichte gewesen. Also, es gab verschiedene Komponenten. Dramatis persone. Wir haben einmal seinen Sohn, dann gab es die Oma und dann gab es eine Gießkanne. Oma schenkt Gießkanne an Sohn. Sohn haut Gießkanne in die Seite, mit der Oberseite. Die Oberseite der Gießkanne, um den Vater, der fährt, zu attackieren. Dieser irritiert von der Gießkanne und oder dem laufenden Podcast, muss die Spurseite wechseln, dort ist ein Auto, er muss beschleunigen, es wird zu schnell, wird geblitzt. Da haben wir es. Gießkanne fällt. So, und hier ist übrigens, Michael hat uns geschrieben und hat uns ein Bild der Gießkanne geschickt. Ah. Also hier sehen wir die Gießkanne, sehr lange Rüssel, finde ich, oder, für eine Gießkanne? Obszön, langer Rüssel. Ich weiss gar nicht, wie man diesen Schaft nennt, ich weiss gar nicht, wie man das Frontteil der Gieskanne nennt. Phallus, Pimmel, Gieskanne, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig obszön. Also ich weiss nicht, gibt es so ein Schaubild von Gieskannen, wie viele Teile hat eine Gieskanne? Also wenn du so eine Gitarre hast, Korpus, Saite, Schaft. Ja, wir haben den Bügel, den Henkel, wir haben den Korpus, das Vasengefäss und den Phallus. Okay, der heisst auch Phallus. Genau, und vorne dran hast du den Diffusor. Oh, okay, den Diffusor, aber du hast keine Basis, keinen Sockel? Nein. Okay, gut. Hier haben wir auf jeden Fall mal die Gießkanne, es gibt auch ein Bild von seinem Sohn, zensiert, also danke. Danke. Aber recht handelsübliche Gießkerne mit einem langen Pappel. Genau, auch recht handelsüblicher Sohn, wenn wir mal ehrlich sind. So, Michael schreibt, und zwar haben wir gesagt, ja, Michael, wir übernehmen natürlich den Strafzettel, denn wir sehen uns in der Verantwortung. Es gibt ganz klar Entschuldigen in diesem verwirrenden Szenario, und das sind wir. Wir sind schuldig an deinem Leide. Deswegen sind wir bereit, den Strafzettel zu übernehmen. Michael, ich habe ihm geschrieben, ey Michael, schick uns bitte die genauen Umstände. Was musstest du zahlen, schick uns deine Kontonummer, wir übernehmen das für dich, kein Problem. Michael antwortet, ich bin ganz glücklich, dass du mich nicht bei dem anderen Namen genannt hast, sonst hätte meine Tochter gleich Bescheid gewusst. Anscheinend hört die Tochter vielleicht den Podcast auch, liebe Grüße an der Stelle. Und nicht alle anderen Details dieser sehr, sehr ausufernden Geschichte könnten die Tochter darauf bringen. Moment mal. Oder ist es die, er hätte doch von seinem Kind immer gesprochen, nur seinen Sohn. Seinen Sohn. Ah, okay. Mehrere Kinder anscheinend. So, so, aber bis jetzt haben sich die Behörden zu dem Fall noch nicht gemeldet. Eventuell hatte ich bei diesem Blitzer Glück, und es war gar nicht wirklich zu schnell. Ich weiss halt nicht wirklich, wie schnell ich war. Blitzer blitzen doch nur, wenn man zu schnell fährt, oder nicht? Wenn ein Blitz, wo ein Blitz ist, ist auch eine Straftat. Wo ein Blitz ist, ist ein Übertritt, ein Grenzübertritt. Genau, wo Blitz ist, ist auch Donner, ganz klar. So, er schreibt, er weiss nicht, ob er wirklich zu schnell war. Mittlerweile weiss ich immerhin, ich hätte anscheinend 100 gedurft. Wie hast du das herausgefunden? Sag mal, es ist aber zum Tatort, Michael, das ist wirklich Fehler Nummer eins, zum Tatort zurückzukehren. Da warten die auf dich. Das ist ein Schulternes. Da sitzen die und warten auf dich. Da sitzen die mit ihrer Polizeigieskanne und sobald du da auftauchst, bapp, haben die dich erwischt mit ihrer Gießkanne, du bist so rau. Hauen die in die Seite rein. Und jetzt, ich muss noch eine Korrektur zu eurer Erzählung geben. Eine. Eine. Also, die Oma sass nicht mit im Auto. Die Oma sass mit dem Anhänger, aber ich dachte, ich hätte nach der ganzen Zeit das Szenario recht bildlich im Kopf. Ja, ich auch. Das bringt mich jetzt komplett raus. Und du musst alles über Bord werfen. Du musst alles über Bord werfen, alles, was du jemals gelernt hast, musst du komplett über Bord werfen. Die Oma, und das ist, glaube ich, einer der grössten Storytwists der Podcastgeschichte, die Oma sass ist glaube ich eine der grössten story twists der podcast geschichte die oma war nicht im auto aber ich finde es gut nur eine rein stilistische frage es gibt kein richtig und falsch aber warum hat die oma so eine grosse rolle gespielt in deiner geschichte weil die oma natürlich die gießkanne geschenkt hat die oma war sozusagen w Waffenlieferant, der auch genannt werden muss mit Ross und Reiter, der hier das Kind mit den Mitteln versorgt hat. Aber Herr Karasek, Herr Karasek, muss denn der Schenker, die Schenkerin dieser Gießkanne überhaupt Anklang finden? Natürlich, Mittäter, natürlich, klar. Wer Waffen liefert, ist mit an der Tat schuldig. Ja, aber ist es für die Story relevant, die wir dann hier erzählen wollen? Nun ja, also es ist ja natürlich was anderes, wenn das Kind dich mit einer Waffe angreift, das du ihm selber geschenkt hast. Die Oma wird hier natürlich zum externen Täter, zum Kompliz. Und die Detailtreue wird zur Banalität. Nun, es gibt eine gewisse künstlerische Freiheit, die man... Das sag ich nicht. Wenn ich das jetzt verfilfilmen würde und ich finde, das ist im Roman ganz glänzend
beschrieben. Ich finde es verwirrend.
Nein, ich finde, das kann man sich durchaus
auch mal eine Scheibe von der Realität
abschneiden, aber ein wenig kreative
Butter daraus schmieren. Ja, das glaube ich, dass jemand das
feiert, bei der Elfriede Jelenik nicht zu schätzen
war. Also jetzt, also die
Oma saß nicht im Auto,
sondern wo denn da, sondern
sondern wir sind von der Oma gekommen. Also, Akt eins fehlt. Akt eins, Interior, Oma. Oma schenkt Gieskanne Sohn. Cut, Cold Opening. Jetzt kommt das Intro. Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da die Gieskane kam. Obwohl, man könnte es natürlich auch akronologisch erzählen. Erst Zitat und dann nochmal was davor gesprochen. Backlash. Wo kommt die Gieskane überhaupt her? Backlash. Dann überhaupt, wo kommt die Gieskane überhaupt her? Kann man natürlich auch machen. Also, wir sind von der Oma gekommen. Das Kind ist zwei Jahre alt und sass vorne auf dem Kindersitz. Dein Bild ist doppelt falsch. Nicht nur hast du die Oma falsch platziert, sondern das Kind auch. Das Kind sass nicht auf der Rückbank, sondern vorne auf dem Beifahrersitz im Kindersitz mit der Gießkanne in der Hand. Jetzt gibt sich ein Bild und jetzt finde ich Opfer und Täter und alles verschwimmt ein bisschen. Es verschwimmt ein bisschen. Und das ist ja das Wichtige, dass man an so einem Fall auch dranbleibt, um die Entwicklung auch mitzubekommen. Weil ich meine, man ist ja ein Geschoss in so einem Auto, auf einer Autobahn ist man ein Geschoss. Sehr schnell. Und man gibt, und Michael, da musst du mir jetzt mal, da musst du jetzt mal tapfer bleiben kurz, aber du gibst eine grosse Waffe deinem Kind, deinem Sohn in die Hand. Man muss wirklich nochmal betonen, wie Schaft ist. Ja, ja, das muss man wirklich noch mal betonen, das ist wirklich schon lanzenartig quasi, was dein Sohn da bei 100 km h. Ich find's durchschnittlich, also ich find's komplett durchschnittlich. Ich find's wirklich extrem lang. Das glaub ich. So, die Gießkanne, also er sass auf dem Kindersitz, die Gießkanne hat er von der Oma geschenkt bekommen. Ja. Siehe Anhang. Wie Anhang? Das Foto von der Gieskanne. Von der Oma, wie sie das immer gibt? Ich glaube, das wurde nicht dokumentiert. Aber dann ist siehe Anhang falsch. Auf dem Foto sehen wir nicht, im Übergabeprozess. Es ist ja einfach nur Begleitmaterial, nicht unbedingt eine Quelle. Ja, aber dann verweist es nicht. Okay, also der Verweis ist abgelehnt. Stefan lehnt den Verweis ab. Also, aber um euch nicht hängen zu lassen, könnte ich euch die Story von einem anderen Blitzer. Ja, ja! Eine weitere Michael-Story. Ein Schub? Ja, dieses Jahr war schlimm. Vier Blitzer in meinem Leben. Oh mein Gott, und ich will jede einzelne Story hören, bitte. Vier Blitzer in meinem Leben und zwei davon innerhalb des letzten Jahres. Scheiße, ja. Also das ist schon ein statistisch auffälliges Ja.
Weil du uns jetzt erst lange angefangen hast zu hören, spielen wir eine Rolle? Das ist natürlich die Frage. So, jetzt lass uns kurz den Einschub beiseite schieben und uns den Satz so nochmal angucken. Ich könnte euch die Story von einem anderen Blitzer oder von meiner Abschleppung schreiben. Mhm, gut, das anderes Thema, Michael. Du kannst es auch aus deiner Kindheit erzählen. Erstmal ist da nichts Falsches dran. Ich glaube, ich bin aktuell eher interessiert an der Abschleppung, weil mich interessiert, wo wir da Mitschuld haben. An der Abschleppung. Also wo ist da, also beim Parken oder wo? Also, ich glaube, Michael hat das ein bisschen beiseite weggeschoben, dass wir bei den Sachen, die er uns erzählen will, spielen wir glaube ich keine große Träume. Ich habe da aber natürlich ein Argus-Auge drauf, das ist für mich natürlich wichtig, für die Schuldzuweisung. So, nächster Einschub, ja, Autofahren war dieses Jahr sehr teuer für mich. Trauriger Smiley.
Wie?
Doppelpunkt und Klammer zu oder doppelpunkt? Doppelpunkt minus Klammer auf, also mit Nase.
Das verortet ihn bei mir jetzt in den Vierzigern.
Oh ja, ja, kann schon sein.
An dem anderen Blitzer bin ich meiner Meinung nach aber nicht schuld, und ich muss demnächst zum Amtsgericht. Amtliches Blitzers? Hab da mal für den Richter ein mehrseitiges Dokument geschrieben. Grinze, Smiley. Michael, du bist eine wirklich, wirklich faszinierende Person. Wie du, wie du durch dein Leben manövrierst, ist wirklich also meisterlich. Unser Freund Michael hat ein mehrseitiges Dokument für den Richter im Amtsgericht verfasst. Kann diese Anhörung bitte, bitte öffentlich sein? Auf jeden Fall. Ausflug. Michael, gib uns wirklich die Verhandlungsnummer, gib uns das Aktenzeichen. Wenn du magst. Und wir sind vor Ort. Wir werden das live reportieren, was sich dort abspielt. Deswegen gibt es ja diese Porträtmaler. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Michaels Tohu-Wabohu-Taktik bei einem mehrseitig verfassten Dokument durchaus helfen könnte, dass der Richter sagt,
okay, ist okay, tschau, sie kommen mit einem blauen Auge davon.
Also, sie fahren hier erstmal mit 120 kmh durch eine 50er Zone, sie fahren über zwei Zebrastreifen drüber,
Sie haben drei Kinder mitgenommen und vier Gießkangen.
und fahren dem blauen Fiat, volle Lotte ungebremst in die Seite.
Aber das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Sie haben drei Kinder mitgenommen und vier Gieskern. Und den blauen Fiat, volle Lotte ungebremst in die Seite.
Aber das Dokument, das sie mir damals, das war schon mehrseitig. Also das hatte schon mehr als eine Seite. Freispruch! Es gibt ja die Chewbacca-Taktik in Anwälten. Es ist auf Bezug genommen auf eine South Park-Folge, wo, glaube ich mal, der O.J. Simpson-Anwalt parodiert wurde, indem er anfängt, einen ganz anderen Case aufzumachen in diesem O.J. Simpson-Fall und auf Chewbacca-Bild zeigt und erklärt, warum der nicht bei den Ewoks leben kann oder sowas. Und das ist super, gar nichts mit dem Fall zu tun. Und inzwischen gibt es diesen Begriff wirklich, ist wirklich Anwaltslingo geworden, ähm, als Taktik, als sozusagen, ähm, um die Uroren und Jurorinnen zu verwirren, indem man so einen Nebenkriegsschauplatz aufmacht. Und da bildet man eine schlüssige Argumentation, wo man so einen Nicken auslöst und, ja, das macht schon Sinn, dass Sparken nicht bei den Ewoks. Ja, ich meine, er sieht ähnlich aus, aber er ist ja jetzt größer. Ja, aber er ist nicht zwangsläufig.
Und es ist ja, nee.
Kommt von Kashik.
Ja, genau.
Ich meine, die Ewoks tragen ja auch rudimentäre Kleidung, ne?
Also die haben eine eigene Kultur.
Aber?
Chewbacca hingegen trägt überhaupt keine Kleidung.
Ja, und daneben ist es halt ein Mörder, aber die nicken dem Verteidiger zu.
Ja, ja.
Und ich glaube, das kann so eine einlullende Wirkung haben.
Absolut.
Wer nickt, ist auch, ja, und dann, ja.
Und dann nicken die dem Anwalt zu, merken sich so, das ist alles meine Interpretation, ich weiß nicht, ob diese Taktik so funktioniert. Eine Konditionierung, ja. Aber ich glaube, es ist eine Konditionierung und dieses nickende, auf den Anwalt bezogene, du hast recht, du hast recht, ja, ja, ja, Freispruch, was du willst. Und das finde ich spannend, weil das eine ähnliche, wie wir Michael kennengelernt haben, kann das eine ähnliche Wirkung haben. Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, das ist alle Strategie dahinter, um aus seinem Strafzettelschlammassel rauszukommen. Ich bin da irgendwie rauszukommen, weil er hat aktuell zwei Blitzer und eine Abschleppung, mit der er sich rumkämpfen muss. Der eine Blitzer wird gerade angefochten auf dem Amtsgericht, der zweite Blitzer kam noch gar nicht an, vielleicht hat er das Glück gehabt. Die Abschleppung ist ein bisschen nebulös gerade noch, was da los ist. Wissen wir nicht. Also, ich habe für den Richter ein mehrseitiges Dokument geschrieben, Doppelpunkt, Minus, grosses D, Punkt. ist wie iniger. Also, gib Bescheid, sonst melde ich mich, wenn ich was Neues habe. Michael, bitte melde dich. Das war das Follow-up zum Gieskan-Case, eine der wahrscheinlich extremsten und brenzligsten Gerichtsfälle, die diese junge Bundesrepublik je gesehen hat, würde ich sagen. Und deswegen bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, wie es da weitergeht. Können wir so GoFundMe-mässig im Podcast Spendengelder sammeln für Michael? Und so wirklich die härtesten Anwälte. So eine Star-Anwältin oder so, eine krasseste Anwältin oder so. So richtig die so Cum-Ex-Verbrecher rausgeballert hat einfach und die einfach da wirklich mit ihrem Team und Stab da einfach aufläuft,
diesem Amtsgericht, wegen so einem 30-Euro-Blitzer.
Und das ist so ein Dorfamtsgericht und dann so, wir haben das Blitzer-Ding.
Und dann ist da so, Margaret McCarthy steht dann da so und sagt, wow.
Und dann dreht sich zur Jury, die es nicht gibt.
What do we see? Was sehen wir? But more important. Aber noch wichtiger. What die es nicht gibt. Was sehen wir? Aber noch wichtiger, was sehen wir nicht? Ja, wir haben das Bild. Und auf ihm können wir auf jeden Fall Michael sehen. Aber was sehen wir nicht auf diesem Bild? Wir sehen nicht das Auto. Wir sehen nicht das Street, die Road, also das Kennzeichen, Frau McCarthy, also wir sehen nicht den Beifahrersitz,
wir sehen nicht den Sohn, wir sehen nicht den Sohn, wir sehen nicht den anderen Kindern. Wir sehen die Gieskanne nicht.
Danke, Matthew.
Wir sehen Gerechtigkeit nicht.
Danke sehr. Vielen Dank. Ich ermittle wieder, keine Angst, ich ermittle wieder, ich bin dran. Und zwar, ich habe ja schon mal erzählt, ich wäre gern Zeuge. Ich mag Verbrechen, True Crime, ich will Teil dieser Welt sein. Ich sehe mich aber nicht als Täter, dafür bin ich zu ängstlich. Ich sehe mich auch nicht als Opfer, dazu will ich nicht irgendwie Stress haben. Ich sehe mich als Zeuge. wenn ich als Kind gefragt worden wäre, was möchtest du werden, wenn du
erwachsen bist? Zeuge.
Ich will Dinge sehen, ich will
beobachten, ich bin dabei.
Oder meinst du Zeuge Jehovas? Nein, nein, nein,
einfach nur, ich stehe im Hintergrund,
ich verfolge
das Spektakel, ich präge mir Dinge
ein. Du hast viel zu grösste Löcher in deinem Zeitung
geschnitten. Genau, ich bin dabei,
ich bin immer da, ungesehen nehme ich Dinge auf, wie ein Schwamm. Sehr auffällig. Um sie dann vor Gericht auszubreiten, um dem ganzen Fall nochmal einen Twist zu geben. Ich nenne meinen Deckmantel, mein Name ist 00Gerechtigkeit, ich bin unterwegs und ich habe ermittelt, und zwar, ich war nachts unterwegs, lass es 22.12 gewesen sein. Gehst du extra nachts raus, weil da die Mörder und Diebe ihr Unwesen treiben? Ich sag immer so, wenn der Bürger schläft, wacht das Verbrechen. Ja. Und deswegen geht er ... Im Sinne von ... Wacht im ... Das ist falsch benutztes Wort. Wachend ist das Verbrechen wachend, öffnet das Verbrechen seiner Euglein.
Und dann war ich unterwegs, kam vorbei an einer Spielhalle. Ohnehin schon immer ein Sulort von Verbrechen unterschiedlichster Art.
Plötzlich fährt ein Auto an mir vorbei.
Ich möchte Creative Commons Detective Musik anmachen.
Oh Gott, bitte nicht.
So.
46 Sekunden lang das Video. Und dann? Es war Nacht. Zweiundzwanzig Uhr zwölf. Nullnull Gerechtigkeit! Nullnull Gerechtigkeit streifte mal wieder durch die Strassen, die ihn so viel gekostet hatten. An jeder Ecke Verbrechen, doch er sieht. Er sieht die, die nicht gesehen werden möchten, er sieht die, die sich verstecken. Und so ging ich um die Ecke, vorbei an der Spielhalle, ein Ort, an dem schon viele Leben verspielt wurden, an dem schon viele Menschen ihren letzten Groschen verspielt haben. Für ein kleines bisschen Hoffnung. Ja, aber was ist denn passiert? Und plötzlich ein Auto fährt Anje vorbei, bleibt stehen, mitten auf der Strasse, vor der Spielhalle, aus dem Auto steigen zwei Männer hastig aus und laufen in die Spielhalle. Für mich war klar, hier findet ein Einbruch statt. Und Nullnullgerechtigkeit hat den Fall aufgenommen. Nullnullgerechtigkeit fing an zu beobachten. Denn mir war klar, niemand hält einfach so mitten auf der Strasse. Es war kein Parkplatz, verstehe mich nicht falsch. Es war kein Parkplatz, verstehe mich nicht falsch. Es war kein Parkplatz, verstehe mich nicht falsch. Es ist null null Gerechtigkeit, nimmt den Fall auf. Die Strasse war blockiert, nichts ging mehr voran. Der Mond schien heller und das Auto fuhr schnell.
Wo bist du? Zeitgekert. Die Nacht ist dunkel, der Schleier legt sich über die Gerechtigkeit hinüber. Also, ich halte Abstand. Halt, Stopp, Verbrechen, Abstand. Ich setze mich also auf die Bank in der Nähe, hole mein Handy raus und fange an zu filmen. Ich filme das Auto. Jetzt ist es eine Straftat. Ich filme das Auto, habe erst das Nummernschild gefilmt, habe mich dann, während ich filme, auf die Bank gesetzt, filme weiter das Auto.
Und ich denke mir, wenn die jetzt da mit gezogenen Pistolen um sich feuernd rauskommen, könnte ich in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden. Ist es mir das wirklich wert? Ende von Null-Null-Gerechtigkeit. Dann ist die Gerechtigkeit am Boden, schreiend, bettelnd, blutend am Boden. Ja, was wäre das für ein Signal für das Verbrechen im Allgemeinen? Also habe ich mich auf der Bank natürlich unauffällig so hingesetzt, habe so getan, als würde ich scrollen, obwohl ich eigentlich ein Video gefilmt habe. Wo du aus Versehen immer das Video beendet hast und wieder. Wo man immer wieder meinen Daumen sieht in dem Video. Und es war vom Winkel sehr ungünstig, weil man kann ja gut nach vorne filmen, wenn man da sein Handy hält. Ich musste aber wirklich über 90 Grad, also so 100 Grad, also so ein bisschen um die Ecke, wo nie jemand auf einer Bank sitzt. Aber trotzdem habe ich versucht, das so natürlich zu verkaufen, wie es geht. Recht auffällig. Recht auffällig. Trotzdem denke ich mir, nein, wenn hier wirklich die Spielhalle, wenn die Jetons geklaut werden hier, wenn die Bananen aus dem einarmigen Banditen geholt werden und die kleinen grünen Drachen, was passiert dann? Natürlich muss ich das filmen. Also filme ich, filme ich, filme ich, filme ich. Und dann? Die Nacht nimmt ihren Lauf, die Bits und Bytes fliessen auf meine Festplatte, immer mehr von dieser schicksalhaften Nacht wird gebrannt auf die Festplatte meines Handys. 20 Megabyte, 21 Megabyte, 22 Megabyte, 23 Megabyte, 3 Minuten,. Oh mein Gott, die können alles auf meinen Zahlen zu sagen.
Vergehen.
Das Auto steht auf der Strasse.
Niemand kommt aus der Spielhalle heraus.
Ich schwöre, wenn das Ende der Geschichte ist, dass sie nicht rauskommt und du bist immer gegangen, flippe ich aus. Ist es schon geschehen?
Haben die Leichen bereits den Boden berührt? Oder hast du zwei Menschen gefilmt, die einfach in die Spiele gehen? Soll ich eingreifen? Weiss ich nicht. Soll ich aus meiner neutralen Rolle des Beobachters heraustreten, eingreifen? Nein, vielleicht nicht, noch ist nicht passiert. Soll ich die Tür aufreissen zur Spielhalle? Diese rhetorischen Fragen waren mich irre. Die um sich mit Waffen starrend herumwuchtelnder Gewalt, vielleicht Aufhalt in ihrem schrecklichen Tun? Nein, Null-Null-Gerechtigkeit beobachtet. Null-Null-Gerechtigkeit ist Zeuge, nicht Täter, nicht Mittäter oder Komplize. Und so vergehen die Minuten. Fünf Minuten, sechs Minuten, 80 Meg Megabatt. Das ist wie ein Lernspiel für Kinder, die Zahlen lernen. Uno minuta, due minuta. Okay, jetzt ist ein Sprache lernen durch Hörspiel. Vergangen auf meiner Festplatte. Plötzlich die Tür öffnet sich, einen Spalt, heraustritt eine junge Dame um die fünfzig.
Vom Fatal.
Um die fünfzig, eine Schönheit, in ihrer Hand die Zigarette, an der sie genüsslich lutscht, zieht, die sie zu tief in ihren mit knallrotem Lippenstift benetzten Mund schiebte. Steckte, ja, immer wieder. Sie zieht, als wolle sie die ganze Nacht einatmen. Der Glimmstängel errötete und erleuchtete ihr Gesicht. Errötete schüchtern. und in ihrem Gesicht las sich Langeweile.
Okay.
Nichts war anscheinend geschehen in dieser Spielhalle. Keine Waffen wurden gezogen, keine Geldsäcke wurden herumgewuchtet. Doch wenn es eines in der Nacht gab, dann Gerechtigkeit. Gerechtigkeit. Und nach sechseinhalb Minuten beendete 00Gerechtigkeit sein Video, stand auf von dieser unscheinbaren Bank und wusste, diese Nacht ist sicher. Vielleicht die letzte Nacht, die jemals sicher sein wird in dieser Nacht. Nice. Das war meine Ermittlung. Das war meine Ermittlung. Ich finde das total gut. Ich mag 00Gerechtigkeit jetzt schon, schon ist eine tolle Rubrik, jetzt schon viel Bock drauf. Jetzt habe ich ein sechseinhalb Minuten langes Video auf meinem Handy von einem Auto vor einer Spielhalle. Nimmt nichts passiert, aber ich weiss genau, wäre was passiert, ich hätte es eingefangen. Ich hoffe, dass diese Musik jetzt passt zu meiner Story. Du hast auch gerade eine Mail bekommen. Nee. Doch, Stefan. Ach ja. Und du kennst die Regel, du musst die Mail vorlesen. Wenn du die Mail während der Aufzeichnung bekommst und man hört das Geräusch, musst du sie vorlesen. Drama Queen Team. Drama Queen ist ein Drehbuch-Schreibsoftware. Drama Queen 3.6 ist da. Erstes Learn-to-do-DQ-Workshop und neues KI-How-to-Video. Dramaqueen 3.6. Liebe Dramaqueen-Autorinnen und Autoren, damit ihr gleich perfekt in eure neue Schreibwoche starten könnt. Jesus Christ. Das ist wie fucking emotional blackmailing. Oh, ihr schreibt noch nicht? Dann mal ran an eure Schreibmaschinen. Haben wir gleich drei Goodies für euch. In Version 3.6 steht ab sofort ein intelligenter KI-Thesaurus für Synonyme und Antonyme zur Verfügung. Ihr müsst beim Öffnen von Drama Queen nur das Update zulassen. Was ist ein anderes Wort für antonym? Gegenteil.
Das Gegenteilige. Das Gegenteilige bedeutet das Ding. Oxymoron.
Ähm, na ja. Gegenteil. Das Gegenteilige, das Gegenteilige Bedeutung des Dingen, Oxymoron. Naja, denn es gibt auch noch einen anderen Menschen, eine andere Rolle, die wir zurückkehrt. Und zwar ist es der beliebte Sankt Stephan. Sankt Stephan, Sankt Stephan, Sankt Stephan ist ein guter Haus und besucht uns und erteilt uns das Lenn und Hansen Stephan Sankt. Und zwar stand ich da auf diesem Platz, um mich herum Menschen, viel los, es war ein öffentlicher Platz, Gedränge, Tauben, fliegen weg. Und ich laufe herum und denke, was kann ich den Menschen Gutes tun? Dafür bin ich da.
Nullnull Segen.
Und ich laufe herum und sehe, der Mann hat gerade seinen Stadtführer fallen lassen. Er hat unterwegs. Ich habe den Stadtführer aufgegabelt, bin hinterher gelangen, habe gesagt, Sir, Sir, Sir, er war Engländer, Brite. Das hast du sofort gesehen. Sofort an seinem Gang und dem schlechtesten Insert. Ich habe gesagt, Sir, Sir, Sir, er war Engländer, Brite, das hast du sofort gesehen an seinem Gang und dem schlechtesten Shirt, ich habe gesagt, Sir, Sir, you lost this book, er hat gesagt, oh, thank you, thank you, thank you, a kindly, kindly thank you, I will give him. Und ein Schritt dann davon, was für ein uncooler Besuch wäre das gewesen, wenn er den Stadtführer hätte verloren hätte. Doch es gibt ihn noch. Es gibt noch den einen. Es gibt ihn noch. Es gibt noch Sankt Stephan. Einen, der hilft. Eine helfende Hand. Und dann bin ich zurückgegangen zu meinem Kumpel und er hat gesagt, du glaubst nicht, was in der Zeit alles passiert ist. Denn während ich das gemacht habe, dem Typen zurückgerannt bin, mein Kumpel da stand, dem ist auch aufgefallen, dass es liegen lassen.
Dann bin ich her und zurückgebrannt. Währenddessen wurden zwei Menschen, wie man es noch nie gesehen hat, von beide, von Tauben angeschissen. So doll, das zieht sich durch mein Leben gerade, von Kopf bis Fuß, die mussten dann ihre Jacken ausziehen und mussten ihr Gesicht waschen. Währenddessen lief irgendwie jemand, währenddessen weg, lief über dem Platz und ich bin in dem
Mittentypen-Nägerin, jemand lief vorbei, Taubenscheissen ihr Gesicht waschen. Währenddessen lief irgendwie jemand, währenddessen weg, lief über den Platz und ich bin in der Mitteln der Kindergern, jemand lief vorbei, Taubenscheissen Menschen an, er hat noch ein Kind angefangen zu schreien, es war wirklich pure Chaos. Das klingt wie eine orchestrierte Aktion von den Tauben, also das da wirklich Ablenkungsmanöver. Ah ja, die haben vielleicht den Mann erschreckt, damit er seinen Reiseführer fallen lässt. Weil die den wollten. Ja, ja, genau. Weil die wissen nicht, wo der McDonalds ist.
Teilweise ist der Platz von Tauben, der Kölner Heumarkt von Tauben.
Von aggressiven Tauben.
Das wollten die rausschwärzen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Aber dann kam er.
Sankt Stephan ist vom Himmel Gott gegeben, heruntergestiegen, um den Menschen die Dinge zurückzugeben, die sie verloren haben. Wieso ist sowas urheberrechtsfrei? Wo ist dieses arme Orchester? Miguel Johnson hat das geschrieben. Der Song hieß Song, das Werk, der Epos Unexplored Moon. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich finde, das wollte ich jetzt mal vorlesen, weil das sehr schön ist, wie jemand das kostenlos der Welt zur Verfügung stellt. Ich finde Hilfsbereitschaft ist für viele Menschen ein unentdeckter Himmelskörper, auf den sie gerne mal Fuss setzen können, denn dort kann man gut leben. Weil er uns das Wasser klaut? Nein, es ist eine andere Dimension der Heiligkeit. Auf eine lustige Art schliesst das den Kreis, zum Anfang. Wir sind zu früh jetzt, aber... Naja, der Mond dreht sich ja immer um die Erde.
Nee, doch, aber er ist locked.
He is locked in.
Der ist einfach so fucking fokussiert, ne?
Ja.
Der ist einfach drin so ...
Wie so Hunde, die sich anstarren.
Ich guck jetzt nicht weg, ich guck nicht weg.
Wenn ich wegguck, passiert was.
So der Mond denkt sich, wenn ich wegguck, dann kommen die Dinos zurück oder irgendwas Geiles.
Aber, und da muss ich recht geben, auch ein bisschen wie so ein Täter, der so ein Messer hinter dem Rücken hat, weil der würde dir auch nie den Rücken zudrehen. Es gibt ja viele Legenden, was auf der dunklen Seite des Mondes sich da... Füchse, Nazis. Füchse, Nazis, Nazi-Füchse, man weiss es nicht genau, was da alles sein soll, aber da ist man wirklich gut versteckt. Es geht. Ich finde ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass man da so gut versteckt ist. Aber wenn man auf der dunklen Seite des Mondes ist, kann man dann mal so den Hals recken und so auf die Erde gucken?
Wie so Käfer.
So Adolf, Adolf, komm zurück, Adolf.
Adolf, wir haben hier extra die ganze Mondbasis aufgebaut, du kannst ja jetzt nicht da deinen Hals recken und mal auf die Erde gucken.
Und die unten, die Astronomen, die uns in den Himmel angucken, war der Hitler, der mit dem Mond hervorgeguckt, hat vorgelugt. Hä, was? Zeig mal, zeig mal. Hä, ich seh nichts. Wer hat mit seiner Luger hinter dem Mond hervorgeguckt? Er hat hervorgeguckt. Ich seh nichts. Ey, ist er weg. Bist du dir sicher? Da ist er wieder, da ist er wieder. Was, was, was, was? Ich seh nichts. Er ist weg, er lugt hervor. Adolf, das kannst du nicht machen, komm zurück jetzt, komm zurück, der ganze Plan ist in Gefahr. Nur wieder, wieder! Was, nein, nein! Du hast es wieder verpasst. Ich will sie nur einmal noch sehen. Einmal noch, denn sie will die Erde sehen. Ja, aber kann sein. Das ist wahrscheinlich dann wirklich da, wirklich schmutzig da auch, oder? Die dunkle Seite des Mondes, wirklich schmutzig. Ich stell mir das so vor, das ist staubig. Kennst du das, wenn man als Kind immer im Garten gespielt hat, dann hat man so einen Stein hochgenommen und dann sind da so Kellerasseln drunter, die dann so ins Licht blinzeln und ich weiß nicht, ob die Augen haben. Aber wenn sie welche hätten, würden sie die Sonne blinzeln. Drecksviecher, die Fühler halt wackeln, die Sonne schrecken. Ekelhafte Drecksviecher. Und so stelle ich mir vor, wenn man auf die andere Seite des Mondes guckt, dass da so ein Wurm liegt. Einfach so anleuchtet, direkt ins Gesicht. Mach es nicht aus. Und dann verschwindet es im Krater so. Wie geil, dass so Insekten einfach unter einem Stein leben einfach. Die können überall leben.
Also ich meine, unter Stein ist ja auch Erde, aber die sind dann in der Erde unterm Stein.
Das verstehe ich immer nicht.
Warum sind die? Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre dann Hohlraum wie bei Patrick, bei Schwammkopf.
Spongebob.
Ich nenne den Schwammkopf.
Du den Stein hast, aber darunter ist ja der Hohlraum, wo sein Bett steht und der Fernseher, da lebt er ja.
Warum willst du ihn beim Nachnamen?
Ich bin der Ich nenne den Schwammkopf, wo du ja den Stein hast, aber darunter ist ja der Hohlraum, wo sein Bett steht und der Fernseher, da lebt er ja. Warum hältst du ihn beim Nachnamen? Ich finde, es ist auch eine Art, also ich nenne dich ja auch den Tietze. Eigentlich nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Nee, aber ich finde es sehr unbequem, die Vorstellung unter dem Stein. Sehr unbequem. Weil ein Stein ist, also wir reden ja nicht von hohlen Steinen, sondern die sind ja unten Stein.
Ja, aber der Stein drückt ja nicht auf den ... Stichwort Quetschangst.
Stichwort Quetschangst, ja.
Ey, es gibt so einen YouTube-Account von einem Typen, der hat keinen Keller und der sagt, Alter, ich will einen Keller.
Und der gräbt halt einfach ein Loch unter sein Haus und stützt es so ab mit so Pfosten und gräbt halt, hat so einen kleinen Minibagger und du denkst dir, okay, ja klar, abonniere ich mit einfach der makaberen Erwartung, dass eines Tages der einfach sagt so, hey guys, I'm just putting the dirt, I'm just, Und einfach ein gesamtes fucking Haus.
Wer hat dann das Video hochgeladen?
Die Cloud?
Nee, ich glaube, dieses makabre Ende, was fast noch schlimmer wäre, wäre ein Tod im Off.
Es gibt dann dieses Video und dann nächste Woche...
Was auch ein klassischer Alfred Hitchcock-Klassiker ist.
In seinem berühmten Film, der Tod im Off.
Der Tod im Off.
Wo der Mord, der gesamte Film, eigentlich interessant, der gesamte Film passiert im Off, so du siehst immer nur Leute, die gucken und so, oh nein und so und du siehst nie die Handlung, Zone of Interest ist ein bisschen so die Idee, aber finde ich eine coole Idee, können wir machen, der Mord im Off, nicht gut. Der im Out im Off. Dann weisst du, dass du als Schauspieler es absolut verkackt hast, wenn deine Rolle im Off umgebracht wird. Dann bist du einfach, dann lass es. Ja, ja, ja. Nimm das mal als Signal wahr, dann vielleicht doch umzuschulen auf Gärtner. Wir brauchen dringend Gärtner. Der Zustand unserer Parks und Gärten ist katastrophal. Da muss jemand eingreifen.
Finde ich wirklich.
Ich habe einen kleinen Park gefunden.
Was hast du?
Ich habe einen kleinen Park gefunden mit einem kleinen Tümpel.
Aber sagst niemandem, wo der ist, weil dann kommen da, dann lungern die da alle rum.
Da lebt ein Storch.
Storch.
Ich habe jetzt mehr oder weniger freien Zugang.
Zu einem Storch. Zu einem Storch. Ja. Ich kann, also nicht jederzeit, das ist Quatsch. Ich habe jetzt mehr oder weniger freien Zugang. Zu einem Storch. Zu einem Storch. Ich kann, also nicht jederzeit, das ist Quatsch, aber ich kann mit einer gewissen, sagen wir mal, 30% verlässlicherkeit, kann ich zu diesem Tümpel gehen und sehe einen Storch. Sag mal, ich bin, ich bin. Ich bin. Komisch, dass du da ich sagst, was du da bei mir hat. Aber Storch? Und dann gehe ich zu dem Storch und bin da und denke mir, alter, ist das ein fucking Storch. Oh, Storch! Der ist da und der ist alleine und der steht da und es ist irgendwie so ein... Im Dickicht. Es ist kein, es ist ein Schilf-Dickicht. Dickicht? Es ist ein Dickicht. Ah, wer ist ein Dickicht?
Der Storch.
Ah!
Er sitzt da.
Er sitzt da und manchmal taucht er auch unter und schnorchelt da so ein bisschen.
Taucht?
Naja, was weiß ich.
Er taucht mit Schnorcheln.
Nein, wie schnorchelt!
Und da ist er einfach unterwegs.
Und deswegen, ich finde das ein Spektakel, es ist, ich würde nicht sagen, wir sind befreundet,
er kennt mich kaum, aber ich kenne ihn. Naja ist aber man sagt docht und nicht docht ich weiss nicht genau für mich ist sprache auch ausdruck meiner persönlichkeit so ein bisschen und nicht einfach nur ein Storch willst du Storch-Typ sein ich glaube nicht dann bin ich ein Storch-Typ ja ich bin ich will mich nicht verändern wenn du bei dieser Datingshow so wär's diese Take Me Out oder sowas. Schleimdinner, oder was?
Wo alle diese Ber haben wo alle frauen eine horde frauen stehen und man kommt da hin horrorszenario für mich kommst da hin und muss über dich reden und dann hauen leute auf den buzzer wenn die dich nicht daten wollen oberflächliche menschen suchen liebe genau so heißt es glaube ich glaube das ist der name und du kommst da hin nicht überoberfälligkeit aber manche fangen an halt wenn jemand anfängt zu sprechen hauen die schon auf den buzzer ich glaube wenn du sagst ja und ich wohne ich habe ein mega cooles haus an dem tümpel und da ist ein lebten Storch würden alle ja ich glaube schon ich habe eher als wenn man sagt Storch dann würde die eine Person die auch Storch sagt aufch sagt, auf den Buzzer hauen. Okay, dann hast du da irgendwie, ja die Johanna, wo ist die und die Dippler Johanna, wo ist die und die Dippler Johanna. Ja, die Dippler Johanna ist verloren. Kann schon sein, ja. Aber ich finde es gut, wenn so bei Datingshows die ganz ekliges Essen kriegen würden bei den Dates. Das ärgert mich immer, dass die bei diesen Datingshows, so Bachelor und so, dass die Rahmenbedingungen so gut
sind. Weil ja klar, hast du
einen schönen Abend, wenn du in einem Sterne-Lokal
krasses Essen kriegst, so.
Da ist mir auch egal. Gute Rahmen zum Beispiel.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Rahmenbedingungen. Genau.
Da hast du, da ist
relativ egal,
ex.com,
da ist relativ egal,
mit wem du bist. Ich finde, die sollten in einem wirklich einfach so Scheimküche. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, im Schleim. Genau und die kriegen wirklich einfach grauen Schleim, der wirklich unansehnlich ist und der wirklich diesen fauliges, farliges, staubigen Geschmack hat. Kellerasseln püriert. Genau, und einfach so, jetzt aber gar nicht so auf super eklig Dschungelcamp, sondern einfach nur so, und ich rede jetzt wirklich nicht von so einem Haferbrei-Schleim, sondern eher so wie so eine Feuchtigkeitscreme, so relativ flüssig. Okay, du hast eine sehr konkrete Vorstellung von diesem Schleim. Von diesem grauen, halb durchsichtigen Schleim. Und dann sitzen die sich gegenüber, jeder hat auch einen viel zu grossen Topf, also wirklich so einen Küchentopf voller Schleim. Und dann, das ist dann das Date. Und dann würde ich mir denken, okay, kann hier Liebe blühen? Könnte auch ein Titel sein für die. Kann hier Liebe blühen? Alternativtitel wäre Schlammschlacht. Schleimschlacht. Aber dann so, finde ich spannend, wenn wir in diesem Haus wären, was so zusammenbrichtend die ganze Zeit. Nicht so ein schönes Bali-Paradies oder sowas, wo die ganze Zeit so alles knarzt und man denkt, oh Gott, gleich stürzt der. Die Heizung geht nicht. Sind wir in dem Haus von dem Typen, der das Haus unterkellert? Das kann auch sein. Die haben immer so eine Kamera, wie der gerade gräbt. Und der gräbt immer tiefer und du denkst dir, okay, ich finde ihn interessant genug, um mein Leben... Also, würde man in einem Haus sterben, wenn das schlagartig ein Stockwerk nach unten rauscht? Nee, nicht zwangsläufig. Nee, oder? Nicht zwangsläufig. Also ich meine, das ist ja so ein bisschen das World Trade Center-Szenario, dass es einfach von oben nach unten rauscht. Ja, wo ja alle überlebt haben am Ende. Ja gut, da sind ja 80 Stockwerke runtergerauscht mit dem oberen Teil des World Trade Centers. Aber wenn du jetzt nur ein Stockwerk runter... Ich glaube, völlig okay. Man würde auch mehr überleben als... Völlig okay. Du meinst, dass auch alles, was auf dem Tisch steht, wieder exakt genauso wieder zum Ruhen kommt und man quasi genauso weiterlebt, nur halt ein Stockwerk tiefer. Und dann ist kurzer Erdachtungsrund momentan, was passiert, bin ich gerade ein Stockwerk tiefer gerutscht und dann würde man wieder weiter, dann würde man ganz normal an seiner Symphonie arbeiten, weil das ist Kapitalismus. Ja, egal ob so ein Stockwerk tiefer rutscht. Wir machen weiter, der Kurs muss steigen, Wachstum, Konsum, Konsum. Weiss ich gar nicht. Könnte nur ein Netflix-Film sein, weil das ja so, das geht ja auch nur noch da. Liegt dir irgendwas auf dem Herzen? Also möchtest du über irgendwas reden, gibt's irgendwas? Erinnerst du dich noch, als du vor zwei Folgen dieses Sankt-Stefan-Intro gespielt hast? Ja. Da hast du im Nebensatz gesagt, da reden wir später noch drüber. Da reden wir später noch drüber. Ja, schönes Intro, sehr schön. Und es war natürlich eine Anspielung auf Sankt-Stefan, dass du endlich heilig gesprochen werden möchtest. Um heilig gesprochen zu werden, haben wir damals recherchiert, der Vatikan gibt vor, zwei Wunder. Stephan, gelang bisher leider nur ein einziges Wunder. Das heisst, du bist gerade 50 Prozent der Anmeldung ist durch, es fehlen noch weitere 50 Prozent. Ein Wunder fehlt noch. Hast du was im Köcher? Planst du, kann man das planen, kommt das da in göttlicher Eingebung? Ich habe mir das zurückgegeben, das ist ein Reiseführer, habe ich den Mann zurückgegeben aus England. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das als technisch gesehen als Wunder, weil Wunder ist ja... Weil er Engländer war? Ja, aber ich glaube es geht nicht... Okay, ja, ich weiß auch nicht... Weil er Engländer war? Ich weiß nicht, ob du mit der Attitüde beim Vatikan weit kommst, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Es ist kein Wunder, weil es Engländer war. Nee, es hat gar nichts damit, es hat eher was zu tun. Weil es ein Reiseführer war? Es geht ja natürlich, dass du etwas Übernatürliches, Übermenschliches tust, wie auf Wasser laufen, die Klassiker, die jetzt in unserem Booklet hier als Beispiel Wunder mal geführt wurden, einen blinden Menschen heilen, dass der wieder sehen kann. Dann ist er blind. Er Er wäre ja nicht blind, wenn man ihn heilen könnte, weil er sehen kann, wäre er nicht blind. Ich weiß nicht, ob die die richtige heilige Attitüde so an den Tag legen oder so. Weil es ein Engländer war. Wenn es ein blinder Engländer gewesen wäre und er hätte wieder sehen können und hätte gesagt, What the, what, what, what, dann hätten wir gesagt, ist gut. Hat der noch viel gemacht, der aus der Bibel, der geheilt wurde? Also ich glaube, wenn du schon irgendwie so 20 bist und dann kannst du plötzlich sehen, das ist schon krass, oder? Ich habe neulich einer Frau einen Rollstuhl runtergetragen, Treppe, die U-Bahn. Saß sie drin? Nein. Wo war sie? Ich habe sie auf die Rolltreppe gestellt. Das konnte sie, da konnte sie hochkommen. Und dann ist sie runtergefahren und ich habe den Rollstuhl die Treppe runtergetragen. Und dann hat mir ein Mann, der nicht geholfen hat, gesagt, kannst du den Rollstuhl über die Rolltreppe runterbringen? Hat er recht, hat er recht. Sah auf den ersten Blick für mich zu breit aus. Und plötzlich kamen Leute in weissen Roben an und haben dem Typen gesagt, sie sind jetzt offiziell heilig gesprochen. Und ich so, was? Sie haben das Wunder. Weil er Engländer ist. Und die sind, nein, das ist alles falsch. Das zweite Wunder einfach. Das ist ein Wunderproxy-Wunderunder. Weil es gibt natürlich einmal den, wer hat denn Jesus gesagt, dass er auf Wasser laufen soll. Petrus so, hey Jesus! Hey! Ja, ich stehe direkt neben dir. Du könntest auch auf Wasser laufen, nur mal als Idee. Immer noch sehr laut. Nur mal als Idee. Ich spiele es immer noch sehr laut. Nur mal als Idee. Sorry. Entschuldigung. Das ist weird. Nur mal als Idee du könntest auf dem Wasser laufen. Ah, okay, ja, cool, Idee. Okay. Huh. Huh. Okay. Okay. Äh, ja, die, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, Achtung, einen Schritt nach meiner, und, oh, ja, geht, geht. Nee, nee, Jesus wäre mit fucking Anlauf, Jesus hätte gesagt, okay, let's fucking go, nimmt Anlauf fünf Meter und macht dann so einen Slide auf dem Wasser. Nicht im Dennis-Evangelium, der vergessene fünfte, das Evangelium des Dennis. Das wird aus gutem Grund nicht gelehrt, obwohl er ängstlich so, oh das ist ja kalt, oh das ist ja kalt, Peter so jetzt zu laut, hat er seine Schuhe ausgezogen, um auf dem Wasser zu laufen? Ja, ne die die sind eingesackt, weil die sind nicht heilig. Die Birkenstocks sind eingesackt. Das ist das Legolas Ding. Wie Legolas Ding? Nee, weil der kann ja auch auf Schnee laufen und dann so, was ist, wenn der ganz viel Gewicht trägt? Welchen Punkt, also wie, was in der Elbennatur, wie funktioniert das? Wo sagt die Magie? Halt, stopp jetzt, Magie bis 100 Kilo, so und dann aber, weisst du, Magie ist doch Bullshit, glaube ich.
Meinst du? Ja, ich glaube es ist Bullshit.
Aber sind für dich auch so Kartentricks Magie oder ist das, geht das?
Das ist auch Bullshit, geht nicht, es geht nicht, ist alles nur Editing, Video-Editing.
Naja, und hat der Mann gesagt, ja nimm doch einfach über die Rolltreppe mit runter, war ich schon auf der Treppe. Da habe ich diesen Rollstuhl über die Treppe runtergetragen, war schwer. So. Und ich war nicht der Heilige, ich war nicht der Heilige. Nee. Ich war ein Loser-Heiliger. Aber das würde ich mir vorstellen, so in so einem Buntglas-Kirchenfenster, dass diese Szene so festgehalten wird, Wie diese arme, hilfsbedürftige Frau, du ächzend und dann dieser Backseater daneben einfach mit so einem, hä? Und wir sind alle in unseren, ich habe so diesen Karhartpulli an und so meine Ramschanzug und er ist, und sie ist auch so normal so ein kleines Strickpulli und dann der Typ in diesem weissen Jesus-Mikellangelo. Er ist viel heller, wir sind so dunkel. Er ist der Heilige der Becksit, er ist der Heilige der Besserwisser. Hä, nimm du einfach einen Aufzug. Becksitus. Oh ja. Und er ist der einzige, der wunderschön Michelangelomässig hell erleuchtet wie so ein Raphael-Gemälde, wenn er so steht und auf mich zeigt. Wir brauchen moderne Heilige, die modern auch einfach mal sagen, Besserwisser, Klugscheisser müssen auch ein heiliger. Und obwohl es ein Gemälde ist, habe ich so rote Augen, wie in so einem Foto. Das ist ein Gemälde mit Blitz. Warum? Ich habe meine Augen zu. Hä? Hä? Trotzdem rot? Hallo, hallo, weil ich Engländer bin. Aber ich finde das, also klar, ich liebe moderne digitale Fotografie, aber das ist schon was, was ich ein bisschen vermisse. Diese roten Blitzaugen, die einfach jedes noch so heimelige, wohlige Familienfoto zu einer fucking Dämonenbeschwörung machen. Es gab so zehn Jahre.
Weil irgendwie von den drei Kindern ein Kind einfach SORTAN!
Einfach so direkt aus den Augen.
So einfach fantastisch.
Es gibt so viele Bilder von mir, so Weihnachten, wie ich so Geschenke auspacke und glückselig in die Kamera gucke, aber Rote Dämonen haben.
Das ist ein Effekt, den kriegt man nie wieder. Ich habe was von Playmobil geschenkt bekommen, habe ich mir auch Sartan. Ich liebe Lego und Sartan. Oh, das Lego-Piraten sind Lucifer. Er ist immer dabei. Komisch, dass der immer an Weihnachten auch auftaucht. Glaubst du, an Weihnachten sitzt Lucifer auch so in der Hölle so? Wollen wir einmal hoch, wollen wir einmal hochgucken? Ja. Nee, die sind da jetzt, nee, lass mal gucken. Heute ist niemand böse, heute sind alle gut. Einmal hoch, einmal hochgucken. Und der taucht dann auf in Form dieser roten Augen. Das werden wir nie wieder kriegen. Nie wieder. Ausser durch Filter, rote Augenfilter, rein mit den Filtern. Das könnte eine Möglichkeit sein, aber dieser Effekt ist für immer verloren. Blut, also geil, das ist Blut im fucking Auge ab. Ich meine, der Rest des Körpers hat auch Blut. Sei nicht erschrocken, die kleine Lisa, über das Bild. Es ist nur das Blut in deinen Augen. Sei nicht erschrocken über das dämonenhafte Bild, es ist nur das Blut. Es ist nur das Augenblut. Das in deinen Augäpfeln pocht jede Sekunde deines Lebens ab jetzt. Das ist keine beruhigende Erklärung von meinen blutroten Augen. Vor allem der gesamte restliche Körper hat auch Blut unter der Oberfläche. Warum ist die Haut nicht rot? Warum ist die Nase nicht rot? Einfach nur die fucking Dämonen-Augenugen und die Zähne, warum sind die Zähne nicht auch rot. Es wäre aber noch gruseliger, wenn sie aus den Nasenlöchern so rote Punkte wäre. Wenn es Blut aufwürde. Ja, das wäre noch gut. Ach, ich vermisse das ein bisschen. Ich vermisse gute alte, analoge Fotografie. Ich vermisse einfach diesen herrlichen, die herrliche Körnung einfach so ein bisschen, diesen herrlichen Polaroid-Look. Ich liebe den ja. Ja, er ist weg, aber es gibt wieder so eine coole neue Polaroid-Kamera, Instax oder sowas. Holst du dir die, Fehlkauf, wird es ein Fehlkauf, wirst du es bereuen, musst du drei Fotos machen und danach nie wieder, sondern einfach weiter mit deinem Handy fotografieren wie jeden Tag, dann spielst du Candy Crush, gehst auf ein Instagram Reel, schaust dir das Horror Reel an, hast Angst, schaltest weg, kommentierst, that's too scary for me guys, why do you show that to me every time, I don't wanna see this, this is too scary for me. Dann ist der Tag auch schon wieder rum. Dann ist der Tag schon wieder rum und wir haben es wieder geschafft. Wir haben es wieder geschafft und dürfen endlich wieder ins Bett gehen. Und dann müsst ihr noch eine Woche rumbekommen und dann kommt schon die neue Folge des Podcasts. Wirklich? Ja, ja! Oh, ich hab so Bock, jetzt nochmal alle aufwecken, ich hab richtig Bock auf die nächste Folge, die wird fantastisch. Ah, du meinst, das hat die doch aufgeweckt und nicht die Satanruhe, für die wir zwischen dich hatten. Ich freue mich auf nächste Woche, es wird fantastisch, da werden wir nämlich wieder Stefan dabei haben. Und vielleicht, wenn alles gut läuft, ist der Flotin auch da, aber ich glaube, er wurde umgebracht, weil er anfängt zu ermitteln, nur nur Gerechtigkeit ist da draußen. Ich werde sterben für die Gerechtigkeit und es ist ein guter Ton.
Verbrecher nehmt euch in acht.
Ja, hau ab!
Ihr habt einen neuen Feind.
Ihr habt jetzt noch die Chance zu laufen.
Hast du einen Cape dabei an?
Ein relativ kurzes.
Ein kurzes Cape?
Ja, weil ich bleibe immer im Aufzug hängen, ansonsten mit dem Cape.
Macht's gut für immer.
Genießt die Zeit, haut rein für immer.
Wapp, wben, hoooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop, roooop